all right so because of our vacation
last week it's been almost two full
weeks since we did our last coveted
update cases
hospitalizations deaths vaccinations
and i i think while there's still
caution
i would characterize today's report is
good news compared to what we were
seeing two weeks ago it did look for a
little bit there a couple of weeks ago
like we might be seeing a pretty bad
turnaround with cases
first leveling off and even climbing
slightly for about seven to ten days and
there were
concerns about are we heading towards a
fourth wave or a fourth spike
that uptick in cases has now reversed
in some states they're still spiking and
we'll talk about why
but the cases are coming back down
deaths continue down
vaccinations have dramatically
accelerated and i
believe after looking at the data
talking to a few doctors yesterday and
today
and just looking at what dr fauci said
recently as well
i believe we are on the path to a very
good situation by memorial day which is
may 31st the last day of may
uh right around eight weeks from today
so let's dig right into the data
cases you might recall peaked at 256 000
a day back in mid-january
and started to decline bottoming out in
the middle of march around
55 000 per day but by the time our break
started
the cases had actually trickled back up
to about 68 000 a day
up from 55k to 68k
and that's when the fourth wave
discussion started
uh the cause of that uptick appears to
be a combination of
unvaccinated people going wild if you
look at for example who's getting the
virus
lately it is more and more younger
people getting the virus not yet
vaccinated but acting as if
we've reached herd immunity combined
with a more contagious
british variant which is essentially
dominant in some places michigan is one
place where we've seen a lot of that
the northeast is another place it
appears as though
we may not be on the way up because
again
cases are starting to decline from that
68k
pop down to about 64. now that's a small
change it's not totally obvious that
we're on the way back down but at least
we're not continuing to see an increase
and if vaccination continues to
accelerate we should see
substantial case declines over the next
eight weeks
and i'll tell you why a little bit later
in terms of deaths
the strategy of vaccinating the most
likely to die
if they get the virus after doing health
care workers of course
is working even as cases leveled out and
we said well
you know deaths are on a three-week
delay from cases we may see deaths level
out
they didn't deaths have continued down
the entire time
you might remember they peaked at nearly
3 500
per day more than a 911 a day in january
they went below 3 000 a day in the first
week of february
below 2 000 a day around february 20th
below 1 000
a day uh in that fourth week of march
and now
down to just a hair over 800 deaths a
day
still horrifying still a tragic number
but one that is now down about 77
from its peak in late january this
should continue because cases aside
even against the variants the vaccines
are nearly 100
effective at preventing death
vaccination
over the weekend the u.s had consecutive
days
with 4 million vaccines per day we are
now
averaging just over 3 million doses
per day this means that every day
roughly one percent of the u.s
population is getting a shot
now it's not one percent is being fully
vaccinated each day a lot of those are
two dose regimens
so still one percent of the us
population is now getting
a shot every day the reason we know this
will pay off
in about six to eight weeks is we look
at israeli data
israel has now vaccinated more than 55
percent
of its population they are basically
wide open
passover was almost a completely normal
passover with gatherings and everything
and cases and hospitalizations
serious coveted deaths are all down
down down dramatically we have the chart
up on the screen for our video audience
it looks very very good now then we get
to
but but but david what about those
variants yeah the variants
are concerning eight nine ten months
from now
maybe even six to eight we may be
seeing new booster vaccines dialed in
for these variants
the current vaccines work pretty well
against the variants they work less well
but they work pretty well
and they are almost as effective at
preventing serious covet and death in
almost every case here's a graphic
from dr eric topple who we've
interviewed on the program i highly
recommend following him on twitter about
the variants against the uk variant
a very modest reduction in vaccine
efficacy
against the south african variant a
little more reduction
we don't yet have real world data about
the brazilian variant
but that's the least prevalent variant
in the u.s and
in vitro studies serum studies show
that the vaccines still work against the
brazilian variant but we do have to keep
vaccinating
faster it's a race what will we do what
will happen
faster these variants becoming
predominant or
vaccination israel is predominantly the
british variant
and they are as i showed you completely
dominating this joe biden today expected
to announce
another major advance in full
vaccination eligibility
remember joe biden about a month ago
said may 1st
i want every state making everybody
eligible
today and it may happen before you
listen to today's show
joe biden expected to announce that he's
moving that up by a couple of weeks
april 19th now there will be full
vaccine eligibility all good news
going in the right direction let's keep
going
many so-called healthy snacks
don't taste that great they don't fill
you up they don't satisfy a craving
which is why you should check out our
sponsor monk pack
and their keto nut and seed bars
delicious sweet snacks with only a gram
of sugar or less
two to three grams of net carbs and just
150 calories perfect for the keto
or low carb diet or anybody who just
generally tries to eat a low sugar diet
like me i love the monk pack keto nut
and seed bars
just a great balance of sweet and salty
soft and chewy but with a nice
crunch from the nuts and seeds you can
get
great flavors like caramel not caramel
come on guys
caramel sea salt sea salt dark chocolate
peanut butter dark chocolate that's my
personal favorite they'll give you
all of your money back if you don't love
it go to monkpack.com the link is down
below and you'll get 20
off any of their products when you use
the coupon code
pacman